so I wanted to create a video on the 23
benefits of OMAD one meal a day diet
which is not really a diet it's a kind
of a type of intermittent fasting well
you're going 23 hours of fasting in 1
hour of eating and yes people love food
but you could actually set it up so
let's say you have a social event or you
go out to dinner and that's when your
meal is to your own friends so you're
not sitting there at a restaurant just
like not eating that would be not good
but let's talk about the benefits number
one you can save a lot of money when
you're only eating one meal a day you'll
probably save at least $600 a month just
on that alone it's going to save a lot
of time so you can do other things that
are productive most people spend a lot
of time eating preparing for food takes
a lot of work number three improving
digestion you're gonna give your
gallbladder a chance to rest the stomach
the pancreas the large bowel especially
if they have irritable bowel syndrome
it'll actually help you heal that it
improves the immune system also it puts
your body into something called autophagy
which is the recycling of junk proteins
and damaged protein particles and
recycles it into new tissue but it also
recycles viruses fungus mold Candida
which also is going to help your immune
system right there so it's kind of an
immune strengthening activity you're
gonna live longer which is a good thing
you're gonna be a lot less hungry you
would think by not eating you're going
to be starving all the time but not when
you totally adapt to fat-burning your
hunger is gonna go away no more cravings
it's gonna make it really easy to do
this but of course it takes a while to
get into this keto state but when you're
fully there you're not going to crave
any more better skin because of the
autophagy and the anti-aging effects your
skin is going to be a lot smoother and
younger increased energy tons of
physical energy number eleven increased
mood if you're depressed you have
anxiety you have to realize that comes
from a blood sugar problem when that's
handled you're gonna your mood is going
to come way up you're gonna feel much
better number twelve increase cognitive
function
this is great for dementia improving
your memory focus concentration all that
will improve 13 decrease inflammatory
conditions whether you have bursitis
tendinitis arthritis that's going to go
away because the blood sugar issues will
cause inflammatory number thirteen
decrease inflammatory conditions whether
your bursitis tendinitis arthritis or
even rheumatoid arthritis this is great
for that decrease blood pressure okay
what causes blood pressure is high
insulin so this program will decrease
insulin your blood pressure will come
down number fifteen heart disease if
there's one thing that will improve your
arteries it's doing in a minute fasting
more than probably any other thing that
you can possibly do if we take the
reverse of that and do high insulin and
you have insulin resistance and you're a
diabetic you are gonna have a lot of
problems in your arteries number 16
improving dementia
okay that's related to the cognitive
function and number 17 is definitely
going to improve if you have diabetes
it's going to actually help prevent
diabetes it's going to improve the
pre-diabetes which is insulin resistance
it's going to improve if not fix
hypoglycemia which so many people have
they don't even know they have that
number 18 it's going to actually help
you if you have a fatty liver it will
take that off the liver number 19 it's
going to turn your body into a
fat-burning machine on steroids
you're gonna lose your belly you're
gonna get a flat belly which is really
cool
number 20 it's gonna really help your
discipline because you're doing
something that is almost an exercise in
discipline or strengthening your
self-discipline and that's going to
improve because your ability to was
stayin from food for 23 hours so it'll
improve your your willpower and your
discipline over that 21 improve your
muscle physiology muscle density and you
would think by not eating you would
worsen your muscles not the case you go
through a whole thing where your growth
hormone improves that's the anti-aging
hormone but growth hormone has a
protective factor against muscle loss so
this is very important especially if you
want to improve your muscle density and
muscle mass number 22 it'll actually fix
your metabolic rate if you have a slow
metabolism this is the thing you need to
do to finally raise it and actually get
the fat off number 23 it's really gonna
improve your mental clarity a lot of
times people we even feel like this
euphoric feeling you're gonna feel
really good all this and they start
eating and then they feel worse okay so
definitely something you should think
about doing food for thought no pun
intended and I will see you in the next
video hey before you go definitely sign
up for my free keto course I put a link
down below it's on messenger in Facebook
but it will give you all the basics it's
very quick it's like three or four
videos and it's free check it out